there's an idea in science called the
null hypothesis and it works like this
when you're setting out to prove a
theory your default answer should be
it's not going to work and you've got to
convince the world otherwise through
clear results so in the last video while
I was trying to talk to a camera up on
that zero-g flight the student
researchers all through the rest of the
plane are who were physicists
psychologists chemists electrical
engineers all of them were trying to
disprove their null hypothesis we want
to seen a brain-computer interfaces can
be used for very extreme situations such
as space and that zero-g or
weightlessness will not really interfere
with the signaling and if it does how
can we filter it out in the flights the
participants are going to play a game
called shoot the alien and they'll do so
with their brain activity simply put
they'll just think of movements or not
actually move and by thinking of that
movement they'll control a little cannon
on a screen if I really move my right
hand I get a certain brain signal but if
I imagine moving my right hand I get the
exact same brain signal that means that
I can learn a computer how to respond to
those brain signals even if I'm not
really doing anything at all and that's
why it's usable for people are actually
paralyzed or suffer from other types of
illnesses we're not actually reading
someone's mind but we're measuring their
brain signals we have a cap which has 64
electrodes to actually measure those
brain signals through the skull through
a special gel that we put in the cap is
actually quite comfortable once it's on
you don't actually feel it anymore so
it's just measuring there it's not gonna
bother them at least we hope it's not in
theory getting a negative result is a
good thing and for the brain fly team
that would be brain activity in
microgravity being too different for the
system to detect and now well as long as
the equipment worked that isn't a
failure that just means your idea has
been proven wrong that's still a step
forward but in practice humans don't
work that way it's called publication
bias negative results are less likely to
be written up by scientists less likely
to be published by journals and less
likely to make it out to the rest of the
world the media doesn't care if
nothing's changed scientific
institutions have limited money and
getting flashy amazing results that
generate lots of press coverage all of
us
good for your career so if you're
putting all that time and money and
there is still a stigma that if you get
a negative result you have somehow
failed we do hope to publish we hope to
get lots of maybe at least four papers
sexually because we all have different
thesis subjects on it in the best case
scenario everything works perfectly the
BCI is still controllable the data is
not noisy all nine participants give
perfect data that's like the dream
results my idea result is actually this
little tiny brain signal called AP 300
which is a positive peak in your
electrical signal so what I think and
what I hope is that microgravity so the
moment when you're weightless may result
in a slight cognitive enhancement so up
there in those twenty second bursts of
microgravity those researchers trying to
disprove their null hypothesis for brain
fly that is is our brain activity
comparable in zero-g
can you still use a brain computer
interface if you're in orbit in a few
decades could astronauts doing
spacewalks use their minds to control
equipment I'm not going to tell you you
can look it up when they all publish
their papers because the achievement is
the same regardless of the results
science has taken one small step forward
no matter whether they disprove their
null hypothesis or not no I'm just
kidding
they got the results they want
if you're a masters or PhD student from
an Eastern Member State and you want to
be one of the people behind me then have
a look at the fly your thesis program
the link is in the description